we've got the latest on the crisis over
ukraine russia's government released
video of troops conducting drills over
the weekend and video of missiles being
launched this morning reuters is
reporting that russia claims to have
killed five ukrainians who they say were
trying to cross a border on a sabotage
mission ukraine says they have no forces
in that area charlie daggett is in
ukraine with more on the story charlie
gets more and more confusing we know
that president biden has agreed to meet
with vladimir vladimir putin if there's
no invasion but you got to say these are
very ominous images
good morning to you
yes good morning to you gail the whole
purpose of those exercises was a show of
force to the world but where it matters
most of course is here ukrainians don't
need reminding that their forces are no
match to russia's military in the event
of a full-scale invasion
but the overwhelming majority of people
here believe or at least hope that
president putin's aim is to launch a
limited invasion to the east where
ukrainian forces have been battling
russian separatists for years now we
went there over the weekend and there
has been a dramatic escalation in
shelling and you may have seen we've
seen those pictures showing uh civilians
be being evacuated
and the fear is that president putin may
use that as a pretext to send in troops
in order to protect
ethnic russians however no one is more
hopeful of a diplomatic solution than
the ukrainians themselves they feel
they're trapped
between russia and nato and don't want
to see that battle played out on their
own soil
vlad
all right charlie dagetta in ukraine for
us charlie thank you very much